good evening and welcome to tonight's
program hosted by the Commonwealth Club
of Silicon Valley my name is Mary Ellen
Hannibal it is my pleasure to introduce
dr. Richard Dawkins evolutionary
biologist founder of the Richard Dawkins
foundation for reason and science and
author most recently of science in the
soul selected writings of a passionate
rationalist dr. Dawkins was voted
Prospect magazine's number one world
thinker and was on the Daily Telegraph's
100 greatest living geniuses list he
earned his degree in zoology and
doctorate in animal behavior from Oxford
University and later returned to become
the university's first Simoni professor
for the public understanding of science
his best-selling books include The
Selfish Gene the blind watchmaker and
The God Delusion
they have sold more than three million
copies and have been translated in more
than 30 languages worldwide ladies and
gentlemen please join me in welcoming
Richard Dawkins
[Applause]
okay are we all can you hear me that
sounds pretty good not bad okay so we
have a lot of heavy-duty questions and
things to ponder tonight so I thought
maybe we would start with something a
little lighter and more personal there's
a really wonderful essay toward the
beginning of this book science in the
soul I have a bound galleys which gives
me a complete license to write all over
these pages which you won't want to do
with your copy of the book but there's
I'd like to read what you so I wonder
dr. Dawkins you have this wonderful
essay about being influenced by Charles
Darwin and by dr. Doolittle how many of
you have read the hugh fleming book dr.
de Latour or seen the film with Rex
Harrison
oh so you all know you pretty much know
that's pretty good well I do think
there's some similarity between dr.
Doolittle and at least the young Darwin
I mean they're roughly contemporary and
dr. Doolittle was always sort of sailing
in little ships rather like the Beagle
and he was a great naturalist like
Charles Darwin and they both loved
animals and I think I was genuinely
influenced by dr. Doolittle I read all
the books I think I've never seen any of
the films thank goodness I'd like the
Rex Harrison is pretty good are they won
that one yeah I always think that if you
really love a book seeing a film spoils
it but but anyway I love dr. Doolittle
and I think he did influence me I think
he influenced me to value non-human
animals in a way that I might not
otherwise have done he's actually
censored in quite a lot of libraries
he's not allowed in public libraries
because of racism and that was just a
symptom of the nineteen twenties which
is when Hugh lofting wrote the books I
mean everybody in Britain was racist at
the time and but in a very gentle kind
of way but I think that dr. Doolittle
more
more than makes up for it by his auntie
speciesism
well dr. Doolittle as you point out in
the essay he he gets into fixes over and
over again in which he has helped out of
them by by other animals who figure
things out what he needs and sort of
form webs of rescue for him yes so he
couldn't he can talk to two non-human
animals and that's really the plot of
all the all the stories and everything
turned on this one trick that he has
he's rather like good science-fiction we
just alter one thing and and then
everything else follows from that well
it struck me reading it this in the last
couple of years we've had quite a number
of best-selling books and some of them
very good for example a book called
beyond words by Karl Safina who was a
wonderful marine biologist a book called
the soul of the octopus by sy Montgomery
who's a wonderful science writer and and
they're focused on animal consciousness
and as Carl Safina says you know animals
care about their own life they want to
increase their own life and they care
about it furthering their own life just
the way you and I do and of course
there's a there's kind of a plea at the
center of these books for us to
understand that we can't just be wiping
these creatures off the face of the
earth and what I like about the dr.
Dolittle analogy or connection is is
that he is helped and aided by these
animals in ways that we are also aided
by animals really without our
understanding how we are connected to
them quite consciously all the time yes
I think it's a bit of a stretch to to
link it in quite that way and it is a
children's book and that's true
all right so you're so right actually
another of another of the early in the
book concepts I mean your writing is so
accessible and it's just charming and
easy to read but then you have some you
know real concepts that really make you
sit down and think about them pretty
hard and one of them I've just been
really pondering a lot is is your your
discussion of how humans and how this
moment in time organisms are adapted
perfectly because of this process of
natural selection which is law-like and
has been selecting genes over eons to to
bring the next generation forth is is
perfectly well adapted to the past but
not to the present or to the future and
that along with that when we have these
aggregates of lots of successful humans
as we have now we have these what you
call emergent I don't know if we're
going to call them qualities or things
that are we create together such as
something like the internet which then
again is a little bit beyond our own
capacity to to deal with perfectly well
we're always going to be a little bit
misaligned with our own present this
idea of time I think an hour placement
in it is is it very beautifully framed
by the beginning opening of your book
and I wonder if you would read from that
so this is the introduction which I
wrote especially for this book much of
the rest of the book is previously
published essays although many of them
not previously published in this country
this is an introduction I am writing
this two days after a breathtaking visit
to Arizona's Grand Canyon breathtaking
still hasn't gone the way of Awesome
although I fear it may
to many Native American tribes the Grand
Canyon is a sacred place site of
numerous origin myths from the Havasupai
to the Zuni hashed repose of the Hopi
dead if I were forced to choose a
religion that's the kind of religion I
could go for the Grand Canyon confers
stature on a religion outclassing the
petty smallness of the Abrahamic s' the
three squabbling cults which through
historical accident still afflict the
world in the dark night I walked out
along the south rim of the canyon lay
down on a low wall and gazed up at the
Milky Way I was looking back in time
witnessing a scene from a hundred
thousand years ago for that is when the
light set out on its long quest to dive
through my pupils and spark my retinas
at dawn the following morning I returned
to the spot shuddered with vertigo as I
realized where I had been lying in the
dark and looked down towards the canyons
floor again I was gazing into the past
two billion years in this case back to a
time when only microbes stirred
sightless beneath the milky way if Hopi
Souls were sleeping in that majestic
hush they were joined by the rockbound
ghosts of trilobites and crinoids
brachiopods and bela night's ammonites
even dinosaurs was at some point in the
mile long evolutionary progression up
the canyon strata
when something could call a soul sprang
into existence like a light suddenly
switched on or did the soul creep
stealthily into the world a dim
thousandth of a soul in a pulsating
tubeworm a tenth of a soul in a
coelacanth half a soul in natashia
then a typical human soul eventually a
soul on the scale of a Beethoven or a
Mandela or is it just silly to speak of
souls at all not silly
if
you mean something like an overwhelming
sense of subjective personal identity
each one of us knows we possess it even
if as many modern thinkers of her it is
an illusion an illusion constructed as
Darwinian smight speculate because a
coherent agency of singular purpose
helps us to survive
so I'll tell you what I wrote in my book
upon reading those those paragraphs is
Richard Dawkins getting spiritual on us
well that's part of the point I mean
it's kind of meant to be a little bit
provocative to put the word soul in but
in the title I said last night that I
quoted one of my great heroes Peter
Medawar great medical scientists and
biologists and Nobel Prize winner he
said I hope I shall not be giving
election said I hope I shall not be
thought ungracious if I say at the
outset that nothing on earth would have
induced me to attend the kind of lecture
you may think I'm about to give and I
then said I hope I may not be thought I
hope I shall not be thought ungracious
if I say at the outset that if you have
come hoping from the word soul to
witness some kind of conversion you're
going to be disappointed that there are
two meanings of the word soul and it's
in somewhere in the book I I quote to
dictionary definitions definitions from
the oxford dictionary one of which is
the immortal soul the religious soul the
supernatural soul the one that survives
your death and that's not what I'm
talking about
and the other is the sort of spiritual
aesthetic emotional response to science
to the universe to life to deep time
deep space that kind of thing that's the
sense of soul in which I use it in the
title I wonder if you could if you could
elaborate a little on this emergent
concept yes well you were saying earlier
about how it's a very interesting point
you are making about how we are adapted
to the past all animals are adapted to
the past not that the genes that made us
our genes that have survived through
countless generations you look back on
your ancestors and every single one of
your ancestors they're not a single one
of your ancestors
died before achieving at least one
heterosexual copulation obvious but it's
very significant because very very many
of their contemporaries died without her
or died young died without having
succeeded in reproducing so we we
contain the genes that helped our
ancestors to survive in the past I've
got a phrase which appears in the book
and have a lot of others of my books the
genetic Book of the Dead the genetic
Book of the Dead is the genes in a
modern animal which in a sense describes
the past there's a the G's in in an
animal can be thought of as a kind of
digital description of the worlds in
which the ancestors of the past survived
not the present and not the future and
as Mary Ellen has just pointed out
emergent properties mean that the future
is going to be different and in the case
of human emergent property is very very
different because we are changing
environment at breakneck pace much much
faster I suppose than any other animal
has ever done in a way it's amazing that
we do thrive so well in an environment
which is radically different from the
environment in which our genes survived
in the past we wear clothes we live in
huge cities we get around in fast cars
and fast planes and things like that we
do suffer from psychological problems
probably because the world in which we
live now is so different from the one in
which biology was naturally selected and
this is all comes under the heading of
emergent properties so there's this very
beautiful passage you know that the
beginning that you that you've quoted
here where you framed of the very very
long geological time frame and then
the cosmic timeframe and then we have
this person you observing both and then
you're talking about this past that we
are very well adapted for but this
emergent future to which we are hurtling
and we're creating it as we hurdle now
this rate of change why has it increased
has it increased have we been increasing
it because of our increased numbers or
what's what's causing this I mean I
think we it is increasing and if you
think about the well you if you go back
to the Stone Age Bronze Age Iron Age and
so on that's you know huge huge spans of
time in between each of those major
advances agriculture ten thousand years
ago ten thousand years or so then the
Industrial Revolution the invention of
printing nowadays we have the computer
we have computers Moore's Law the
exponential increase in the power of
computers the speed and economy the
speed and cheapness of computers we're
living in an astonishingly fast changing
world and it's no showing no signs of
slowing down it's it's still
accelerating so two questions kind of
related to that one is it would seem
that that it's that we are almost we're
driven by our own invention of our own
tools the tools of perception in
particular starting with a little more
referencing perhaps Galileo's telescope
but satellite technology the microscope
the ability that we have to drill down
ever ever deeper to ever ever more you
know finely granulated discernments of
what reality is and then you know in
this in this way that becomes very
social like with the internet and
Facebook and Twitter becoming ways that
we actually organize ourselves socially
it would seem that our tool making is
actually driving our social behavior in
many ways
and I wonder what you think about that
it's not like we decided that our arts
that our culture that our understanding
of history would be what determine us
but our our tool-making is really the
thing it would seem yes and I think
there's a kind of it's it's rather like
what biologists call a coevolution of
advances make way for the next advance
and in in our case I think we have in in
the world of computers we have software
hardware a coevolution where advances in
hardware make possible software that
wouldn't have been wouldn't have been
possible before the hardware was
invented and then so each one paves the
way as it were opens the door for the
next advance and that is getting faster
I have to say it would seem that one
thing we're sort of dispensing with kind
of willy-nilly as we go is is biology
the biology biological reality of other
species one of the things there seems a
couple of thresholds that we've passed
without really fully grokking what we've
done one is that the aggregate number of
human beings on this earth has become a
bio geophysical force
discernible in the fossil record the
American Society for geophysicists or
the American I never get it right but
they want to now call our époque the
Anthropocene to reflect this in profound
impact of humans on on life on earth now
one of the things that we're doing is
we're reducing biodiversity of other
species the way that some scientists put
it is we're using up too much
photosynthesis so we're actually
depriving other species of
photosynthesis but mostly it's really
that we're taking away their habitat
because we're putting so many more human
bodies on the earth that we're
converting their habitats to human
buildings for people to live in and
agriculture to feed people but but we're
doing something very scary to may very
dangerous and and kind of tragic which
is reducing diversity itself and I
wonder if you could tell us about
diversity in a
you know going back to the very profound
and simple mechanism of natural
selection and how it depends on
diversity how our life has Defense
dependent on diversity and what are some
of the how do you see the horizon as we
take it out I think it's more your
subject than mine actually Mariel and I
mean I I mourn as you do the loss of
diversity and I'm I mourn the extinction
of species if only it's an aesthetic
level I mean I think I think it's some
that there be mass extinctions before
and sometimes people say oh well the
mass extinction the so-called six
extinction that that humans are now
causing it's no worse than the previous
ones no worse than the one that wiped
out the dinosaurs and things well maybe
not but it's tragic and I I respond to
it in an emotional aesthetic way I I'm
on the loss of Silas Silas I mourn the
the loss of the dodo the passenger
pigeon but what you're talking about is
something bigger than that which is that
the catastrophic loss of species and
ecologists tell us that it this is more
than just the loss they actually are
species are actually necessary for the
continuation of the balance of the other
ecosystem you know I think it intersects
pretty pretty strongly with with your
expertise because you know you were
talking about the the genes that are
this genetic book of life when I first
started writing about evolution myself
and I was taught by evolutionary
biologists that some species like an
octopus has conserved speech this
conserved genes in it that are so
ancient because it octopus is eventually
way back in time evolved from ammonites
from from different species that some in
some cases no longer exist but that
those conserved genes that have
persisted through the
yawns are very likely to be genes that
are the most Hardy and the most
adaptable to future scenarios so it's
very important actually to conserve
especially species that have those
ancient lineages because those conserved
genes are perhaps more important than
more recent genes that's very
interesting I didn't know that that is
interesting it is it is fascinating how
some animals have have conserved things
for very very long times and other
others have this enormous variance in
the in the the the in the in the sheer
age of genes yes well good to go back to
your own words because it really is more
important to stay in your world although
I think they overs over intersect quite
much right in that introduction you have
a sentence that says it's not an
unreasonable speculation that the
progressive growth of consciousness and
the infant mirrors a similar progression
over the longer time scale of evolution
does a fish say have a rudimentary
feeling of conscious personhood now to
connect that a little bit with another
essay that you have somewhat later which
is a really fascinating essay about the
Internet in which you you wonder if if
here's here's a sentence from it the
chapter is called net gain and it's
about how the Internet may be changing
the way we think and here's your
sentence the unplanned worldwide
unification that the web is achieving
mirrors the evolution of the nervous
system in multicellular animals and then
a little bit later you say the cloud is
a superhuman interstellar traveler who's
nervous system consists of units that
communicate with each other by radio
orders of magnitude faster than our
puttering nerve impulses but in what
sense is the cloud to be seen as a
single individual rather than a society
yes I mean I should interject there that
this cloud that you're talking about is
is from science fiction it's a massage
fiction book by Fred Hoyle Fred holism
is or was a great astronomer and he
wrote a lot of science
much of it not very good but his first
science fiction his first science
fiction book is extremely good is called
the black cloud and it's marred only by
the obnoxious hero which you can't help
wondering maybe modeled on the also the
same obnoxious hero keeps turning up you
know you know Fred Hoyles under a
different name and it's supposed to be a
different character he's always always
equally horrible anyway the black cloud
is a superhuman mega mega super human
organism that appears that comes towards
the summit of to feed on the energy of
the Sun and eventually the human
scientists on earth get in touch with it
and manage to communicate with it and
learn about it and it different parts of
the of the cloud communicate with each
other by radio and the scientists raise
the very interesting question in what
sense are you the cloud a single
individual and the cloud replies well if
the question doesn't mean very much when
they when the rate of communication the
speed of communication between the
between the different communicators is
very very fast you might as well stop
talking about them as different than
individuals altogether and if all of us
could communicate telepathically with
each other instead of having to go
through the slow bottleneck of speech if
we could all as it were communicate our
thoughts directly by at the speed of
light speed of radio waves then we would
be one individual wouldn't mean anything
to actually talk about ourselves as
being separate individuals and I think
the point you're getting at is that the
internet may be moving towards a sort of
science fiction future where it becomes
a single
being a single living organism of some
kind and I think also enough of the
passages you read made an analogy with
the development of a child where it's
been suggested that the consciousness of
an individual child forms itself as a
kind of melding of separate entities the
child starts off not as a single agent
at all but becomes a single agent
through the same sort of melding as we
just been talking about it's pretty it's
all pretty fascinating it's it's as
Charles Dickens said the best of times
in the worst of times I mean looking at
it both ways it seems exciting yeah
that's what that's the way I feel on the
west of time and then it's terrifying at
the same time speaking of which just
reading I was rereading The Selfish Gene
which I read many years ago and I was
reading a very contemporary book called
the gene which is just out in the last
year which is also very good and I was I
was just remarking to myself how how how
timeless your book The Selfish Gene is
that the the profundity of what you're
explaining in that book hasn't changed
that much in the decades since it was
published thank you for that that's I'm
glad about that well in my my opinion
but a couple of things have changed
and one is our ability to mess with the
gene so now humans can we can alter the
gene at the germ level we take out we
can suppress the expression of certain
genes and we've also developed the
ability to insert influences on genes
and I wondered if you would explain what
CRISPR is to the audience some of you
probably know but not everybody does and
and tell us what you think about this
this moment in time when we've perhaps
become the blind watchmaker ourselves
yes
as it happens I've read I read coming on
the plane coming over from England a
very interesting book on CRISPR by
Jennifer Doudna who lives in these parts
she's a professor at Berkeley going on
planes is a wonderful opportunity to
read books isn't it you're now separated
I read this entire book between London
and New York reading an entire book by
the ways more than Donald Trump has done
and his whole atom
[Applause]
genetic manipulation the actual changing
of genes is something that has been
possible to do only relatively recently
and one of the main ways of doing it has
been to transplant genes from one
organism into another one and you've
probably heard about cats that glow blue
because they've had jellyfish Jesus put
them in them and things like that
CRISPR is a new technique which Jennifer
Doudna was one of the main pioneers of
and it's a wonderful book I do recommend
it it's called
Kraken creation and it's kind of semi
autobiographical about her career but
it's it explains all about the the
technique of CRISPR and the misgivings
that she has about its possible misuse
and the power that it might might have
it is a very very powerful fast
technique for changing or actually
writing actually programming genes in
organisms any organism you like it comes
from bacteria that teria have their own
immune system against viruses bacteria
are very very heavily afflicted by
viruses called what they called phages
that's right Thank You bacteria phages
and the the technique that bacteria use
in order to recognize viruses in order
to in order to kill them is a technique
that humans can now exploit in order to
edit genes of any organism you you you
like so it's an immensely powerful new
technique and it's giving rise to great
possibilities and also great misgivings
whereas in the past until for the for
several well actually thousands of years
we have controlled evolution by
manipulating the selection part of the
Darwinian equation the non-random
survival the non-random
production we've controlled that to
produce dogs that are wolves that had
been changed in Topeka nieces and
poodles and Bulldogs and corn that
corncobs changing from that size in the
wild to huge great things cabbages
things like kale kohlrabi cauliflower
broccoli all these things are modified
versions of the wild cabbage Brassica
oleracea that's been going on for
hundreds of years but now we can
actually change the mutation part of the
Darwinian equation not only the
selection part and this is much faster
much more powerful potentially very
dangerous and people are worried about
it so yeah I mean we recommend the book
very good this might sound like a very
it might be an over simple question but
let's say someone messes with a gene in
humans and creates some some kind of
human that is dangerous and from science
fiction could what would happen after
that is is it possible that we that
something could be released that could
never be well I suppose it is it I mean
the the sort of ethical discussion
partly centers on the distinction I so I
do croak a bit because I had a stroke a
year and a half ago and it's the one
thing that still there is this is my
croaking voice the the distinction
between negative and positive
manipulation it's already being used
quite successfully and with rather
little objection I think for removing
genetic disorders things like
haemophilia Huntington's disease to shed
muscular dystrophy things like that
there are some people who even object on
an ethical grants of doing that messing
with nature meddling with nature playing
God much more people object to positive
manipulation trying to
change the genes of a of a human so that
they become better at music say or
mathematics or high jump or or running
or something like that a lot of people
have objections to that I think partly
because it sort of smells a bit of
Hitler trying to make sort of blonde
blue-eyed Aryans what he called Aryans I
think that you do need to make an
important distinction between draconian
dictatorial government imposed genetic
changing like Hitler was doing and
voluntary it's it's you can still object
to people the idea of people in the
future going to a doctor and saying
doctor I want my child to be a brilliant
musician please give her the right genes
which may be possible and it's not
possible yet it seemed inevitable that
we will do it I mean yes and and there
are people who do do object to that
meant many people object to that
actually and I can kind of see why
although if your sort of thing a little
bit laterally we don't worry too much
about parents who are ambitious to make
their child into a brilliant musician
and force the child to sit down at the
piano for three hours a day and work at
it is that really all that much
different than putting a bar gene into a
child
I think I'd rather have the G drill
everything work but still it people are
are what are worried about that and a
nightmare visions of regiments of Saddam
Hussein sort of marching over the same
jeans at a brave new world Aldous Huxley
kind of world as you said Marion in the
best of times and the worst of times it
the future can look pretty scary
sometimes we have some really fantastic
questions from this incredibly literate
audience and I'll since we're kind of on
a technical topic I will read this one
there has been many there have been many
recent advances in abiogenesis both in
the area of potential RNA components and
metabolism what are your views in this
area abiogenesis we're talking here
about the the beginnings of life that
the creation of life from non-life which
has to have happened at least once it
has to happen at the origin of life it
may have happened more than once and
it's one of the big mysteries that faces
biology we don't know how it happened it
happened about four billion years ago
and they've been various theories of how
it might have happened we know the kind
of things it must have been we know it
was it was the origin of the first
self-replicating entity in in in effect
the first gene once you've got the first
gene it needn't have been DNA almost
certainly wasn't DNA once you've got the
first gene the first self-replicating
entity then that's the prerequisite for
Darwinian natural selection to get going
once that started then the whole story
can take off and you get competition
between genes then building cells to
live in and then bodies composed of lots
of cells and so on and once that started
then we kind of understand what happened
we know then Darwinism took off and gave
rise to the full diversity and
complexity of life but how did that
first step happen
it's a huge mystery it couldn't have
been DNA almost certainly couldn't have
been DNA that started because DNA is
what's being called a high-tech
replicator it's a very very efficient
replicator but it needs a complicated
infrastructure of protein in order to do
its replication and you can't have a
complicated infrastructure of protein
unless you've got DNA so we have a
catch-22 is we call the catch-22 of the
origin of life RNA is a related molecule
to DNA as many of you no doubt know and
RNA has always kind of weakened
replication property it is a replicator
it's not as good a replicator as DNA and
it also has the capacity to be an enzyme
like protein so RNA could have done both
jobs you remember I talked about the
catch-22 of the of the origin of life or
you can't have DNA unless you've got
protein new contact protein let's see
what DNA if you've got RNA it can do
both jobs you can do the job of DNA and
the job of protein so the sort of
current most fashionable theory of
abiogenesis at the moment is that it was
RNA that first started things off and
then the replication function was taken
over by DNA and the enzyme function was
taken over by by protein I'm gonna
aggregate a few questions that have to
do with machine machine learning and
artificial intelligence ones is how do
humans adapt to the coevolution of
machines and their inevitable evolution
to learn is is there a point that we
must unplug I guess that's kind of a
question about worrying as another one
of the questions does about artificial
intelligence that there's a
question references Elon Musk's
anxieties about a possible threat from
artificial intelligence yes
Elon Musk is worried about it and you
caught you and you must listen to Aaron
mask I mean he's he's Elon Musk is a
genius and there's no doubt about it so
Stephen Hawking and he worries about it
as well
I am I suppose that as a philosophical
naturalist I'm committed to the view
that there's nothing in the brain
nothing in our bodies nothing in our
brains that isn't physics I'm committed
so therefore to the view that anything
that our brains can do potentially can
be simulated can be done also by
machines so I think it is definitely
possible that machines will do
everything we can do and likely that
they'll do it better so it may not
happen for a long time but in principle
it's possible and various people
including Elon Musk are worried about
about it some people are worried about
are not being necessary anymore all our
jobs are going to be taken over by
robots and maybe we will be dispensed
with altogether if they if they get to
the point where they could make their
own children make new new robots and
they don't won't even need us at all and
so we we go extinct and our creations
take over maybe they'll do a better job
than we do
I don't know why would be we would be so
particularly worried about that really
well I'd be I'd be worried in exactly
the same way as I'm worried about losing
the rhinoceros and the elephant and it's
it's an aesthetic thing but for me I
think I think I would I would be sorry
if Shakespeare and Mozart and Schubert
and Michelangelo were forgotten and
nobody knew about them but of course
there's no reason why the robots
shouldn't not have not only know about
Shakespeare but actually appreciate him
because we remember we're talking about
robots that can do everything that
humans can do fall in love be wowed by
great poetry and great music maybe write
better poetry and better music
no no so best of times worst of times
yet again it's scary terrified but at
the same time exhilarating well we've
got a number of different questions here
about religion so I'll try to watch the
sack is them a little bit
so when are liberals afraid of Islam if
you could ask believers one question to
most shake their beliefs what would that
question me I have a question about the
statement that you make in one of your
essays that says will understand
religious behavior only after we have
renamed it and in that essay you're on
didn't hear that's a you say will
understand religious behavior only after
we have renamed it so when we have
understood what what religious behavior
has been good for or why it evolved and
then we don't have to call it religion
anymore we can just understand that it
served a purpose or perhaps still does
yes I think what you're talking about
there is when I was when I was talking
about the evolutionary advantages of
religion where which in a sense there
has to be we are challenged to produce
an answer the question what is the
Darwinian survival value of religion and
the reason that we're challenged to do
that is that religion is extremely
widespread it's it's ubiquitous in human
cultures and all human cultures I think
have something equivalent to religion
and suggest it really is that a human
universal and therefore probably does
need some kind of explanation and I what
I said was which is what you're quoting
there what I said was that we have to
rename the question before we cannot
before we can answer it it may be it's
the wrong question to say what is the
survival value of religion it may be
that the right question is what is the
survival value of some psychological
predisposition which manifests itself as
religion under the right circumstances
so that's that what I mean by the
renaming we're reduced riving the
problem it's no longer the cooler
question what's the survival value of
religion it's what's the survival value
of a psychological predisposition which
might be things like tendency to obey
Authority a tendency to believe what
your elders and better
tell you a tendency to be scared of
dying something let's say a combination
of psychological predispositions which
manifest themselves as as religion
rather than ask the question what's the
survival value of religion I think
that's what I was meaning here but what
was the question that the card said
before you because I didn't really hear
that here's here's one there's a couple
of them humans are getting rid of
religion and replacing it with new age
whew rather than skepticism how do we
get rid of this danger dangerous
emerging trend another person wondering
what your thoughts on the future of
religion and governments are in the age
of artificial intelligence and never
dying super humans and I think if you
are going to puncture someone a
believers belief how would you do it
what would be your main way to do that
right okay well to take the last one
first puncture read the Bible
[Applause]
what was the earlier one our liberals
afraid of Islam sorry are liberals
afraid of Islam are liberals afraid of
Islam yes I mean you I think the
question of there may be referring to
the tendency for sort of nice people are
people my kind of people to abandon
their principles when talking about the
horrors of homophobia and misogyny and
things like that all these things which
we all hold dear when we hate misogyny
we hate homophobia but when it comes to
Islam this there are many people in this
country and in Britain you forget all
about that and say oh well if you own oh
we don't criticize that because that's
religion that's there that's part of
their culture what a patronizing
condescending thing to say
margin Nahr was who is an ex-muslim X
almost Muslim terrorist actor actually
who now runs a magnificent foundation
called the Quilliam foundation to try to
reform Islam he coined the phrase
regressive left for this tendency to as
it were give Islam a free pass when you
talk about your principles about
feminism and about homophobia and and
things like that I think that it's that
this regressive left tendency in the in
liberals stems from partly from a terror
of being thought racist because they
mistakenly think that Islam is a race
which of course it isn't
well you laugh but it's very very
widespread if you can convert into it or
apostatize out of it it's not a race
so that's I think that's that that
that's part of it I think also it's a
it's a laudable tendency to identify
with victims of oppression and we all do
that at least I hope we do and but I
think they have identified the wrong
victims they think that Muslims are
victims of oppression from the West
actually Muslims are the victims of
oppression from Islam especially Muslim
women Muslim gays X Muslims
apostates that that's the real
victimization that that's the real
problem and so I think we need to do for
magic now as they're trying to reform
Islam from from within and and that's a
very good thing to try to do ayaan Hirsi
Ali strive to do the same thing we in
the liberal community in the West need
to reform our view of who is the victim
here and who is doing the victimizing so
we do have a big problem with with this
idea of trying to reform religions that
are oppressive to people's human rights
and yet saying that we should reform
them is only talking to people who
already agree that we should not be
oppressing other people's human rights
what do we need to replace religion with
some other kind of code of behavior what
what what could be effective and
changing the way that people aggregate
their communities around values I mean
people that will criticize your position
on religion say you're not getting the
whole thing about religion because
religion is because science does not
explain everything and there are there
are beliefs that people have that are
spontaneous and continuous over
generations through history through
literature through art through music
many of the finest expressions of human
creativity of
and what we would call religious so we
can't just get rid of religion one of
there's a there's a lot there and and I
mean there's there's the salads count
explain everything science can explain
everything about the real world
what's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now I mean art and music and and
morality and their their their different
matter science can't tell you what's
right and wrong probably although Sam
Harris might disagree there but science
certainly can help you enormous Lee in
thinking clearly about what to do about
what's for what's right and wrong you
can identify logical inconsistencies in
your moral position using scientific
reasoning and moral philosophical
reasoning which is the kind of
application of scientific method of
thinking to moral questions now things
like you mentioned art and music yes I
mean many many great works of art great
works of music are inspired by religion
it's a great mistake of course to think
that that makes religion in any way
valid to true or anything like that
nothing to nothing nothing of the sort
it it's entirely natural partly that
great music and great art should have
been inspired by religion because in
past centuries that's where the money
was and artists and musicians are
sponsored by rich benefactors in Bach
was employed as a as a church
Kapellmeister for example Michelangelo
was employed to paint the Sistine Chapel
but also religion of course does provide
did or has always has provided genuine
inspiration I mean this is the story of
Jesus's passion Jesus's crucifixion is a
tragic story which not not surprisingly
inspired great artists and great
musicians and we we don't we shall never
know what might have if science if say
Hyden had written his evolution oratorio
as that of his creation or
or Beethoven's mesozoic Symphony you
have you asked what what what do we
replace religion by well for all sorts
of different purposes from for morality
we replace it by moral philosophy for
music and so on I suggested you have
mind slightly facetiously that science
and indeed reality could provide
inspiration perhaps every bit as
beautiful as or just nature provides
beautiful inspiration for art community
religion has provided community where we
can do that in different ways we don't
need religion in order to provide a
sense of community a sense of oneness so
what do you think is going on here why
why do we have Donald Trump as our
president
scientifically speaking well I mean
partly because you have this dopey
electoral college system which by the
way is not quite so difficult to get rid
of as as as people often think on paper
it's very very difficult to get rid of
because you need a two-thirds majority
in both houses of Congress I think and
then and then it needs to be ratified by
a substantial number of state
legislatures so just simply to abolish
the Electoral College at one stroke is a
very difficult thing to do but the
Constitution does allow each state to
change the way it chooses its delegates
to the electoral college now
Maine and Nebraska as you know do it in
a pro-rata way but they're very small
and so it doesn't make much difference
if California were to suddenly do what
Nebraska and Maine do okay a disaster
because I mean it so you you you you
can't do that what you can do what do
what you could do is for individual
states in their own way decide that they
will follow the Constitution and send
all their electoral college delegates
one way or the other but California for
example could decide that all its
electoral college delegates will vote in
the electoral college the way the entire
country vote so they would look at the
the popular vote in the entire country
and say right they they're all gonna
vote that that way and that can be done
on a state-by-state basis it's not it
wouldn't be a drastic sudden change in
the way that suddenly going over to the
Nebraska main system would would be
it you don't have to wait until a
substantial number of states agree to do
it which is which is there there is this
move movement afoot as you as you may
know waiting for a certain number of
states to agree to do it
I don't you need wait for that because
individual states can do it it won't
make much difference to begin with but
it would get rid of the anomaly that you
have at present I think the electoral
college when it first started was
probably rather a good idea and if you
could have a true electoral college
where instead of the Electoral College
members being pledged to vote for
particular candidates that's when the
raht set in if the Electoral College was
a group of people elected to go to
Washington sit down together and
deliberate or who would make the best
president rather like we do when we
choose a new professor or a new
chancellor of the university or
something take up references read their
books read them
since we do have Trump as our president
interview them so that that the
electoral college what why have we got
Donald Trump well I recommend Michael
Moore's analysis if some of you've seen
his his his I mean he he was one of the
few people who got the prediction right
and he sort of talking about Rust Belt
people feeling inferior feeling left
behind feeling that their world is
disappearing and they need defending
things like that so if you haven't seen
his his he's an analysis well worth
looking at so to tyre to tack us back to
more scientific questions perhaps and
since we do have Donald Trump as
president I think this this question
might wrap it up well if a catastrophic
event resulted in the death of most
humans and rendered all electronics
useless how long would it take for
humans to evolve to survive in the wild
without technology and then a related
question from another person asking can
humans do you think humans will ever
evolve to the point of speciated
so that we actually become split off
into more than one species yes well
speciation requires that there should be
some separation so that there's no gene
flow between the incipient species and
normally this happens by a geographical
accident time okay normally this happens
through a geographical accident where a
population gets split perhaps part of
the population finds itself or on an
island and so there is no gene flow
between them and so they are free to
evolve in different directions and that
is not going to happen on this planet
now
isn't the opposite kind of happening
where we are we are becoming so much of
flowing into each other that we're
actually yeah exactly so the only chance
for humans to speciate would probably be
if a colony was set up on Mars or
something where and there was little
gene flow between between them so that
that was that question and the other key
for getting what the earth was if you
could the move to push the time since we
only have time for one last question I
think that I'd like to ask you what you
would like to tell us if there's
something that you didn't come up
tonight I mean you are a person to whom
we are looking very earnestly for
guidance and helping us to synthesize
things that very often really feel very
separate our moral values our knowledge
of science our technologies our our past
our comprehension of our place in the
universe and what would you like us to
understand what what do you feel like
most of us are not getting it um I think
evidence is the only reason to believe
that anything is true
[Applause]
personal opinions feelings emotions are
fine and we all have them but they do
not tell you what's true and they don't
and they should not guide important
decisions like who you vote for and what
what you do what policy decisions that
you that you take evidence is the only
reason to believe anything that's as far
as believing things as is concerned
where morality is concerned ethics is
concerned that needs to be intelligently
designed don't base your morality don't
base your politics don't base your
ethics on holy books or tradition or
revelation or authority based it on
intelligent design sitting down together
and trying to design the kind of society
you want to live in yeah ok that's it
that's it
[Applause]
so I hope you have enjoyed this
evening's program brought to you by the
Commonwealth Commonwealth Club of
Silicon Valley we would like to thank
Richard Dawkins author of Science in the
soul selected writings of a passionate
rationalist our audience here in Santa
Clara and those of you joining us on the
radio and the web and now this meeting
of the Commonwealth Club
is adjourned